aucun principe aux valeurs les plus
importants que la vie de mon peuple
on vivra paisiblement
[Musique]
tu as you can
qu'est ce que vous savez de one man une
épée à la place du cerveau
je dois faire en sorte qu'ils viennent à
moi où est elle
où est ma fille
on traverse en dépend vous verrez un
camp d'esclaves
vous savez bien que tout ce que j'ai
fait je les fais pour le bien de cette
nation
pour moi
sept enfants émanation
pfff
regarde tes yeux tu vois bien que tu
n'as pas la moindre chance une épée une
séquence
trancher et poignardé
qu en est il des collectes j'ai entendu
dire qu'il y avait un problème tu es
oubliée acquis du parlement je suis
l'ancien chef de la police il y a une
faim dont aides à domicile mansare des
monnaies
[Musique]
elle est où fait gentiment ce que je te
dis de faire et tout se terminera très
bien
j'ai besoin de toi ce soir et de
certains de ses anciens talents pour
collecter des paquets 5 adresse suivante
il ya beaucoup de monde qui attend
impatiemment que je fasse ce genre
d'erreur tu transportait de la drogue
pour les russes tu faisais des courses
et dans toute la région de moscou
c'est qui cette fille tu sais très bien
qu'ils allaient de mettant en travers de
son chemin
ce sont pas bons du tout
je sais qu'elle a défendu eric et ses
gars juste sous votre nez de flics
pourris et si j'étais vous je
commencerai à inquiéter au sujet de ces
salopards
[Musique]
il me faut une réponse êtes vous avec
nous ou contre nous
on se tire d'ici
tu as trois autres paquets récupérer
il faut que je récupère ma fille
si je fais ça je me mets en danger
fut comme l'impression que tu n'as pas
vraiment chaud
quand on joue contre vous
[Musique]
encore trois paquets à récupérer
et encore deux paquets
plus qu'un paquet récupérer
[Musique]
débarrasse moi tu sais
[Applaudissements]
allo gens il y avait des bouchons
monstres sur le chemin de l'aéroport
j'ai raté mon avion
je déteste les aéroports à vous qui êtes
fous tu excelles textor
je sens en vous un petit esprit curieux
vous êtes un businessman regardez autour
de vous c'est mon havre
[Applaudissements]
et toi avez vous déjà tué quelqu'un
je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux
et de visualiser l'histoire que je vais
vous raconter dans les moindres détails
je suis désolé mais on sait pas déjà vu
je ne crois pas non je suis désolé
c'était une totale perfection pourquoi
vous faites ça parce qu'elles ont
vraiment des questions
mais mensonge doit toujours être répétée
pour être cru contrairement à la vérité
[Rires]
deux ans que je cherche ce que vous
savez
cette porte
à quoi ça rime votre petit jardin croyez
que c'est un jeu mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez
la perfection est atteinte non pas
lorsqu'il n'y a plus rien à ajouter mais
lorsqu'il n'y a plus rien à retirer
[Musique]
regarde
la salle de bains et donc c'est à qui
forme une de mes patientes lors des
gériatres oui bah je sais pas alors
sénat c'est à toi ça non un loisir on se
protège en plus je peux pas être picorer
mais c'est pas toi ça c'est quoi ça
[ __ ] mais c'est dégueulasse non c'est
pas qu'on puisse des masses alors et
maxime jaming boeuf qui fait de la
musique de chambre et du pilat qui
t'arrange toujours pour être cernée par
des neuf semaines mais c'est parce que
ça il a une sensibilité
singulière bien sûr
[Musique]
et je n'ai pas cette marque à free
demandé jones qui tousse c'est sûr
c'est pas comme ça
quand tu deviens maire la première fois
quand tu dirais une maman dit
tu joues à l'adulte
vision latérale pourquoi
force de faire semblant
au sud et un adulte je suis complètement
défoncée ses heures tu m'apprends le
rolland du corps tu perds tu l'as
toujours
on ressente wayma une famille heureuse
on a une jolie famille d'eau
je faisais trop de temps libre on
retrouve des occupations madame question
des loisirs enfants nous lâcher un peu
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
va commencer au début nom prénom date et
lieu de naissance jésus je suis né y ait
un peu plus de mille ans mais vous vous
y tenir je suis jésus il part à dîner ou
dans tout ça c'est voulu transformer
paradis en enfer bien voilà on faire
c'est moi je suis là pour te pourrir la
vie est comme ça un jour tu l'apprécient
et vous voulez quoi au juste notre ami
va bientôt nous quitter j'aimerais
offrir sa dernière histoire d'amour elle
va faire des gones l'ont clairement
comme ça pourtant c'est une mauvaise
imitation de devenir dali revenir au
csad aignan qui tu parles pas de mort tu
parles pas de vie et à la vie à la mort
avec lui tout est bio afin et 1,8 fils
et les 10
et à votre père
[Musique]
vous êtes venus seuls sur ce bateau oui
pourquoi pas parce qu'en général quand
on vient seul sait que c'est qu'il ya un
problème m'a donc vous aussi vous avez
un problème alors vous êtes vie je vais
me consoler avec le premier venu c'est
ça aussi le premier venu n'est pas le
dernier décompte pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
penser que l'amour ces mecs-là vie
maintenant oui
cette soirée a été un immense succès et
c'est grâce à toi on n'a qu'à laisser la
voiture là et prendre un taxi tu sais
quelle heure mes parents rentrent ta
maman m'a envoyé un texto pour me dire
qu'ils allaient partir
tu pourras leur dire de venir me dire
bonne nuit quand ils rentreront
je suis sûr que c'est rien tu n'as
absolument rien à craindre
on est marchand d'art on voyage un peu
partout pour vendre des oeuvres
inestimable
vous savez un jour j'aimerais vraiment
avoir tout ce que vous avez
je vous prie
on
trouve là effet la terre
tout va bien
ouais
on m'avait pas prévenu de tout faire du
mal
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mais la gamine je la trouve
pas
n'oublie pas pourquoi on est là il faut
concentrer nos plans
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'ils sont prêts
il devrait arriver d'ici quelques
minutes contente toi de faire comme on a
dit pareil de mon côté
pitié ne fait rien la famille
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas me faire confiance
vous savez un jour j'aimerais vraiment
avoir tout ce que vous avez
salue les productions salué pour le
châssis thomas la vendent mal là-bas le
youtube rats succès qui s'apprête à
dépasser la leader de followers sur sa
page que tu es là tu le pacs de savoir
ce que va faire tobal là-bas pour sa
vidéo du mil et aux grandes entreprises
j'espère qu'on en direct sur la chaîne
si je voulais tu sois la star de ma
vidéo du million
là on est tous choqués sur la dernière
vidéo et à poster thomas la main le mec
a fondu quoi mais ça va être des tentes
et abris colosse pas comme c'est eux
découvraient lighters ouais mais là il y
en a vraiment beaucoup
on va sélectionner dix et on va aller
les voir pour de vrai dans la vraie vie
et on va voir si je me dis rend pas il
est calculé à l'ordinateur de tim
thomas
qu'est-ce qui me l'a peut-être ben moi à
la base elles émettent de grandes gfa to
make her say est un peu qu'on en fait et
plus je les rencontre pas dole plus je
réalise qu'en fait tant qu elle ceux qui
ont la rage contre moi c'est parce
qu'ils ont la rage contre eux mêmes je
veux une grande part dans ta gueule
parce que juste le reflet de ce qu'ils
aimeraient être il leur compte c'est moi
je pence
franchement ta gueule
regardent ils tentent refuge pour
animaux il est minuscule il va faire
quelle taille ce dépôt de l'amour que tu
lui donneras
[Musique]
est arrivé un truc tu crois il flatte un
hippopotame
à noël j'suis dès mon
arrivée la grande aventure
en famille et bien le royer on s'amuse
on se régale il mange comme un animal
est un animal par dont je parlais de lui
au home ces merveilles
c'est un super sorcier ou quoi chez ton
amour qui l'a fait grandir à ce point
ou ceux habitant
[Musique]
j'espère que je serai pas à côté pour la
suite
docteur winter ravi de vous voir vous
avez quelques heures avant votre
première consultation
bonjour me dis
qu'est-ce que tu dessines manille
j'aimerais mettre la main sur le dossier
de son ancienne clinique le mieux de
prendre un nouveau départ avec ce
patient
qu'est ce que ça représente un accident
c'était aux infos suis moi qui les fais
tu as eu comme une vision dans ton
esprit
viennent dans votre tiroir
est-ce que manier aurait pu entrer dans
mon bureau avant ou après un rendez-vous
non
à l'eau
depuis que je suis arrivé ici tout
semble si est réel c'est là que les
problèmes commencent en ressassant
vous l'avez rendu réel en regardant en
ouvrant ce tiroir donc notre façon de
penser le monde ne devient elle pas
notre monde restait en fait il doit y
avoir une explication logique à
travers toi
parle-moi de cette offre l'homme avec
les cheveux ébouriffés est-ce qu'il peut
être sauvé non
tu envie d'y jouer
j'ai le contrôle à
je dessine la réalité je détruirai tout
[Musique]
alors dit moi vous en êtes avec votre
projet salut je m'appelle et me dit ce
parc je vous contacte depuis la terre tu
crois pas qu'il ya une raison qui fait
que tu aies la moins aimée de l'école
a favorisé les rêves de christopher de
communiquer avec les extraterrestres
emilie nous sommes mêmes gars super
proche de communiquer avec qui existe là
où imagine ce que ça va être quand on va
enfin y arriver ça va être vraiment
[Musique]
qu'ils nous laissent entrer
c'est arrivé dans cette ville il ya plus
de 50 ans et il n'y a eu qu'un seul
témoin
frédéric match les monsieur jeunes qui
habitent en bas de la rue sa maison est
hantée
[Musique]
les enfants aux yeux noirs c'est la
période de la récolte
mais pourquoi ils vous demandent s'ils
peuvent entrer ils n'ont pas le choix
ils ont besoin d'une permission et
surtout quoi qu'il arrive ne jamais dire
oui non sectaire la police va s'en
charger les gestes tu ne bouges plus de
chitwan en vous comprenez pas innocent
criminals et quand tu tournes nous
[Musique]
tu peux m'en sortir d'ici vivant